so you and chiron were a relationship
that came out of this I just got done
with my interview with him and I need to
hear from you where are you guys that
what is your relationship side we're
working on it confused
he's like working on it I'm like your
girlfriend he's like we have a feather
what is the deal clear it up for me
Rhonda the world is not in our favor
right now we have not been able to see
each other since coming back home it's
been a year
I know it's look and now we're dealing
with survivors it's just one thing after
the next it's been so hard I work I was
a full-time manager he was a coach for
you know underprivileged kids he did all
this stuff and we kept trying and trying
it just never works because I remember
you at I'm in Atlanta okay but though
it's still just a slight a post your
right your right is just a quick flight
instead the quick fight but it just did
not work I don't know it just didn't
work okay right weird breaks but we
still talk on the phone we still face
time we're still supportive of one
another but if we can get together I'm
sure it'll pick up where it left off no
problem he told me he's not hooked up
with anybody else and you have not
either
no but so then why okay we've we've been
quarantine in a month why this is 11
months wouldn't you want to see him and
wouldn't you want to touch him and kill
him and all that what what was why
wouldn't you'd be like no matter what
I'm getting on a plane I wanted to and I
wanted to so bad but it did not work
I went over 60 hours a week and then of
course I am a parent that was full-time
parenting mostly by myself so it's like
I can't just up and fly I have to get my
baby situated you know I had to get my
life situated and it was just so hard
and he has family here too so he was
like it's perfect I'll come visit them
too well that makes me question him then
why
when he cried right I'm just telling
we're going to woman Rhonda why didn't
come to see you I love it
that's why we were just like hey let's
just take it a day at a time like it was
hard enough cuz the adjustment for him
was way different for me like as a mom I
guess I kind of snapped back into
reality and I'm like okay I'm home time
to do what I need to do for him he was
still trying to figure it out like
missing us kind of detaching from us for
a second to kind of gather his thoughts
so it was a process we had to go through
I mean not only tell me why you are
still holding on to him when he didn't
fly to come see you for 11 months what's
new
stay in touch because that experience
that we went through and the way he
opened up to me made me appreciate and
respect him so much more and I feel like
we haven't really had the opportunity
yet for me to just say I'm not even
gonna give it a shot if the opportunity
came so right now it's just I have it
because right now I'm protecting my own
II I'm focusing on myself building
myself as a brand I am from Nepal I'm
working on all this other stuff so I'm
like while we're building as our own
individuals eventually we're gonna build
together I'm pretty sure
so you see him becoming your boyfriend I
can see you so thinking do you have sex
hands is there a date post quarantine
well it depends the quarantine can trace
back you can't my birthday is coming up
so I would have had plans fail and I'm
just like I don't even know what now I
can post date Skype well so you
obviously you know you're into this min
enough for him to have met your son and
he told me he's facetiming with him yes
so what is your son think he is is he
does he think that's your boyfriend or a
friend or what what's what is that
explained us to him he's just like oh
that's mommy's friend cuz before he
didn't know much but now he's like a
talker so I have to be very careful
mom who's that is that Daddy no who's
that like if I named job he'll start
name droppings on life it's mommy's
friend but you know he says he's had too
many run songs so who took him while you
were on the show my mom and my sister
was that hard no I mean it was but
luckily I was able to FaceTime Hannya
you know periodically that really helped
but he wasn't really worried about me
which helps because he had my sister has
four kids
it's my mom's down there his aunts and
grandparents so he had so many people
don't distract them from me it was
harder for me so another couple that
came out of this is Harry and Francesca
and I just talked to them and they're
like we're getting married we're having
babies oh gosh I said this to Harry I
challenged him on it do you think
Harry's ready to get married and have
babies he's 22 what do you think you
know these people yeah I love her I
don't know what to say um I wouldn't say
marriage I mean if they really care for
each other that's great marriage
probably not so much um but I mean hey
it's a broader if they feel like
marriage the way they want to seal the
deal go for it I feel like it's a lot of
money we can wait and push it back
like long as you love me say you mutt
right here I'm good but hey you choose
Oh Oh what's the best for the birds
look I lived through it with them so I
know the roller coaster I completely
understand what did you think of their
connection in the house and what do you
think of that they're together now I
think it's amazing that it together now
shocks me I was like okay that's great
you know cuz we keep in touch
periodically yeah but um throughout the
show I was very questionable about it
but you know I was like I have to give
her friends fair opportunities so there
was kind of some ups and downs about it
about kind of how they were going about
their relationship versus how we ensure
wrong what about
hours so it's kind of like there's no
wrong there's no right but it was just
like they did learn something from it so
I respected it much more after time went
on sounds like you don't have total
confidence in their connections I'm
hopeful well you know when you go on
these things you do question like why
are people going on did you feel like
people went on for their careers for
fan-in really for love why did you kind
of feel like everybody was there um
getting to know everybody I was kind of
like everybody already had their own
thing going on so I was like wow this is
like a group of talented people and
individuals all raised I was like I felt
like I was out of place I was like what
am i doing myself so almost like they
got clothing on they got sunglasses like
you know and so I don't really feel like
anybody was there for any ill intent
more for the experience because when I
heard about it I was more excited about
the experience I mean a chance lling
money on an exotic island I was just
like right now I've never done anything
like that so just like then we all kind
of stepped out our comfort zone and was
just like I'm gonna go for it again not
knowing what we were in store side off
what are you going to do with the money
you're gonna be a mom with it
Corso Stratton put some savings but like
I said I'm definitely gonna work on
myself as far as branding myself I do
have a couple ecommerce stores that I'm
working on as far as like pure love such
as more like you know accessories and
things like that so I'm trying to be
very frugal and smart about it and I
just blow it as much as I want to but
hey right now I can buy a $20 ticket
anywhere so I might just plan far ahead
and save up maybe Chiron should buy the
$20 to Atlanta and uh I don't know if
Sherrod knows really has here I'm
serious you are so beautiful you're
okay like I don't okay are you keeping
your options open
yeah so like if somebody great came
along tomorrow you'd have to say sure on
put up or shut up or what do you do it's
now or never